brawl in cellblock 99 is from the
director of bone tomahawk and stars
Vince Vaughn as an ex-boxer who finds
himself doing a stretch in jail there he
finds himself in a brutal fight for
survival in which he must make it up
into the ranks of the most feared
prisoners to find someone to keep his
wife and unborn child from danger if you
have a love of 1970s action movies
commonly referred to as the grindhouse
era then you are going to really enjoy
this movie it is brutal
it's violent it is badass and Vince
Vaughn gives the performance of his
career he's been really great in a lot
of comedies swingers wedding crashers
dodgeball I really liked him in a lot of
serious films as well most recently
hacksaw bridge I thought he was really
good in the lost world as well it was a
more comical role but he had a lot of
serious work in that movie too this just
might be his signature role that people
remember for years have you seen this
film I cannot imagine anyone else
playing this stone-cold man who's very
good at hiding his emotions but in
moments of quiet and moments of solitude
when we find him alone in this cell you
begin to see just how damaged and
tortured he is he's a real man's man
though so he hides all of this of course
and we only get to see his anger and his
rage burst in the middle of incredible
fight sequences this movie takes a page
out of the John wick book and we get a
lot of wides very long takes of action
sequences but unlike John wick which has
very brutal combinations and a lot more
choreographed fights this is a film that
is just about a huge guy six foot five
using his fists to pummel his way out of
things people break things across his
face people go at him with all different
types of objects and it feels almost
like he's not face like he's some kind
of Frankenstein monster it's so damn
entertaining and I loved every minute of
this movie it's a little over long
because it does draw out a lot of
sequences it surprisingly has quite a
bit of
for character it takes a lot of time
before we actually get to the prison
sequences that I thought the entire film
was going to be about because I didn't
watch any trailers I didn't know what
the movie was about I just knew the
title of the film and so that made me
think there's probably gonna be a big
fight scene in a prison there's a lot of
stuff that happens before that to set up
his character to set up his family life
to show his reluctance at turning
towards crime but also it helps you
understand why he does because of his
love for his family and he has no other
options
this film surprisingly takes quite a bit
of time to meditate on this character to
show him in quiet moments to have a lot
of long takes in which he is simply
eating in his cell and you begin to feel
like you are rotting away in that cell
with him this movie makes you feel as if
you are being put in prison it shows
every little detail about how he gets
there including the line to give his
belongings away when they have to check
his body his introduction to his cell
and what prison life is actually like
you feel like you're there this isn't
just a movie about some action sequences
inside a prison it's a surprisingly
effective character drama that has some
brutally entertaining badass fistfights
my only real issue with this movie is
one of pacing it might be just a little
too long because it does take a lot of
time to set up this character and while
it gives you more of a reason to care
about him I was surprised at its length
and it might be a little too long there
were a few things they perhaps could
have cut out also there is a very
obvious prosthetic shot of something
that is very much so not a human being
and part of me wonders if it was on
purpose because a lot of films of the
1970s action era and horror of course
had a lot of very noticeably fake
mannequins and body parts and I feel
like in today's high definition era this
choice had to have been obvious it had
to have been something he did on purpose
but if it wasn't it was a pretty obvious
mannequin and it could have been better
but beyond that this film is dreadfully
entertaining extremely bloody and
violent and Vince Vaughn gives the
performance
of his career I had a blast with it I
did watch it on Amazon video it's
available now and I highly suggest
checking it out I'm gonna give Brawl in
cell block 99 and a - also just as a
reminder I mentioned this in my geo
storm review the premiere of this short
film that we worked on this year
auditorium 6 is going to be this week
Wednesday October 25th at atlas East
Gate Cinema in Cleveland Ohio the link
to buy tickets is below in the
description they're not gonna be sold at
the theater just at this link it's six
bucks and that six bucks will get you a
showing of the movie it's 35 minutes
long as well as a Q&A afterwards with
myself the cast will be there of course
the crew will be there I also have
posters that the cast and I will be
signing to give away and I really hope
to see you guys there again that link is
in the description below and I really
want to share this movie with you as
much as I can and of course for those
who are asking I will have it available
in the future after a Film Festival run
we'll try to make a blu-ray or something
that we can distribute for people who
can't come to a premiere or to any
festivals or who are outside of the US
we'll try to make sure as many people
can see it as possible because I really
am excited to share with you guys we're
very proud of it thank you so much as
always for watching and as always if you
liked this you can click right here and
get steppen eyes
[Music]